most people recognize that the
gravitational force attracts them
towards the earth and keeps them stuck
on the planet but the gravitational
force does so much more than that it
attracts any object with mass towards
any other object with mass so for
example this table is attracted
gravitationally to the chair and the
chair is attracted to the table this is
a beautiful symmetric idea because it
means that every object you can see
around you is attracted to you
gravitationally and you are attracted to
it the reason we don't notice that
attraction is because the force is so
small so today I'd like to show you how
to calculate the size of the force of
attraction between any two masses so in
this example we'll call this mass 1 and
this object mass 2 the force is
proportional to mass 1 so the larger
mass 1 is the bigger the force is the
force is also proportional to mass 2 the
bigger that mass is the bigger the
forces now the force is what we call
inversely proportional to the distance
between them squared so if the distance
between their centers is called R then
the further apart they are the smaller
this force is and that makes sense now
to make this a true equality we need to
add big G the universal gravitational
constant this is just a number a
constant of the universe which tells us
how strong the gravitational force is
this number G is 6 point 6 7 times 10 to
the minus 11 Newton meter squared per
kilogram squared as you can see it's a
pretty small number so the force is
going to be relatively small so let's do
an example
let's calculate the force of attraction
between me and say hello deke
this is my twin brother hi everybody so
the force F is going to be equal to the
gravitational constant six point six
seven times ten to the minus eleven
times my mass which is 70 kilograms
times dekes mass which is 70 kilograms
oh no I thought you were putting on a
little weight
no hey Stephanie 70 kilograms and
divided by the distance between us which
is what do you say about 1.5 meters
don't forget to square it I wasn't going
to forget okay so this works out be one
point four five times ten to the minus
seven Newtons
there is a tenth of a millionth of a
Newton attracting me and deke and that's
not all dude
now Newton is the amount of directed to
me